[Music]
do you believe there are alien
civilizations out there
and how do those civilizations compare
with us how do we even measure it
well we have no idea what an alien
civilization would look like
humans are evolved primates what if an
alien species is reptilian
or more like an insect or a hybrid of
these or maybe something completely
unique that we couldn't even imagine
there is only one set of universal laws
that every species must follow
physics specifically energy and one way
to measure a civilization is by its
energy consumption
and this is done with the kardashev
scale by using the kardashev scale we
can address some big questions about
alien civilizations like fermi's paradox
which says if the universe is full of
advanced civilizations
where the hell are they right that's
fermi's paradox in a nutshell
it's estimated that there are 40 billion
earth-like planets in the milky way that
could support life
now certainly a few of these should have
given rise to intelligent life
and if so where is everyone a recent
study done by researchers at jpl and
caltech states
that when a civilization finally reaches
a certain point on the kardashev scale
it destroys itself which is why we
haven't discovered any evidence
they're all gone that's depressing and
the kardashev scale addresses the most
worrisome theory of
all if there are advanced civilizations
in our universe
it's probably best if we don't make
contact with them
let's find out why
for hundreds of thousands of years human
technology didn't advance very much
tools were useful discovering fire was a
big deal the wheel
super helpful breakthroughs in astronomy
mathematics and physics certainly
happened
but there was a lot of time in between
major discoveries then the industrial
revolution came along and everything
changed
and in the past couple of hundred years
the human race has experienced an
explosion of scientific progress
then the computer revolution accelerated
that progress
now think about it just over 100 years
ago nobody thought human flight was even
possible about 50 years later we're
walking on the moon
and now we're flying drones on mars
things are moving along
and given this rapid advancement of
technology you can't help but wonder
what we'll be able to achieve in the
next hundred thousand or million years
if there are alien civilizations in our
universe who have achieved levels of
scientific progress beyond our own
how do we grade and compare them well
one of the most popular metrics for
doing this is the kardashev scale
in 1964 nikolai kardashev theorized that
courtney's my favorite
what courtney carter chef love her no no
no no nikolai kardashev he was an
astrophysicist courtney's not an
astrophysicist
courtney what the is up with your
wi-fi you have this big-ass house
and you can't afford a wi-fi box out
here it's not about affording it's about
radiation you're gonna die anyway you
understand that right die with a good
snapchat going
she's the best anyway kardashev said
that civilizations can be categorized by
the total amount of energy available to
them
and how much they use plugging how much
power a civilization uses into a formula
gives us a number that represents the
advancement of that civilization's
technology
and the formula is simple oh yeah real
simple
p is the total amount of power a
civilization is capable of using at a
given time
k is the number assigned to represent
their technological advancement
that's the kardashev number and
kardashev defined three levels
levels one through three and these have
since been expanded by another four
so the levels are now zero through six
let's go through the levels and see
where we are on the scale
a type zero civilization is entry level
this civilization harnesses some of the
energy of its home planet but not to its
full potential
as you might have guessed that's us
we're currently about a 0.7 on the
kardashev scale
maybe 0.75 will reach type 1 in anywhere
from 1 to
hundred years now a type one
civilization is capable of harnessing
the total energy of its home planet
think burning timber for cooking using
coal
building geothermal power plants using
hydroelectricity
dams even harnessing the power of the
atom to heat steam and move turbines
two kilograms of matter converted
entirely to energy
per second now this can even be extended
to collecting starlight coming down to
the planet so
solar panels or satellites that can
collect the sun's energy and wirelessly
beam it back down to the planet
for use and this is where we're heading
now the good news is we'd be able to
control our environment entirely
as a type 1 civilization we could
control the weather volcanic eruptions
and earthquakes
we could influence the evolution of
plants and animals
now the bad news is we'd have more
energy demand than supply
so to keep advancing we'd have to leave
earth and start mining other planets and
asteroids for their resources
now if that sounds like sci-fi that's
because it is
actually the best way to describe
civilizations as they climb the scale
is through science fiction so let's do
that
a type 2 civilization can harness all
the energy within their own solar
system still science fiction but
theoretically it could be done with
something called a dyson sphere
sometimes called a dyson shell and this
is a structure that completely
encompasses a star and captures all that
star's energy
the object does fit the general
parameters of dyson's theory
this is one of my favorite theories and
it needs its own video but the the gist
of it is this
imagine building a giant hollow sphere
in space
and the sun is actually at the center of
the sphere now the edge of the sphere
would be about as far
out as the earth is 93 million miles or
150 million kilometers
now civilization would exist on the
interior surface of this sphere
now that's a lot of surface area in fact
it would be about 550 million
times the surface area of the earth so
plenty of room to move around
now even though a dyson sphere works in
theory this is just way beyond our
current level of engineering
the biggest problem is there just isn't
enough raw material
available in the entire solar system to
build it but an intermediate step
could be a structure called a dyson
swarm a dyson swarm is a large number of
independent satellites orbiting in dense
formation around the sun
and these structures would use wireless
energy transfer that would beam energy
between swarm components
and ultimately back to earth now there's
actually a star where a dyson swarm
may exist it's designated
eight five kic-8462852 also known as
tabby's star tabby's star emits such a
wildly changing and varying amount of
light and energy
that it can't be explained by our
current understanding of stellar physics
there seems to be some kind of ring of
matter orbiting the star
and some have hypothesized this could be
a dyson swarm
under construction that sounds crazy but
people are taking this seriously
in fact in 2018 scientists began
speaking of using the european space
agency's gaia mission
to seek out dyson spheres and other
megastructures in the galaxy
now if they're there we should be able
to detect them
that is unless they don't want to be
found now what would a type 2
civilization be hiding from you ask well
a type 3
civilization and that's where things get
really scary
i mean if there are super intelligent
aliens out there
they're probably already observing us
that would seem quite likely
and we just are not smart enough to
realize it
a type 3 civilization would span the
entire galaxy
colonizing and controlling numerous
systems it would be able to harness
store and use the energy output of all
stars in that galaxy
this civilization would use planets like
building blocks moving planets from one
solar system to another
they could merge solar systems merge
stars even create stars from scratch
the galaxy is their playground and
everything in it
is a toy now to reach type 3 the energy
harvested would be
insane it's a huge number i mean we're
talking hundreds
if not thousands of dyson spheres
scattered throughout the galaxy
or alternatively tapping into a
supermassive black hole at the center of
a galaxy
now this civilization almost certainly
would use some form of faster than light
interstellar travel
utilizing wormhole technology to form
shortcuts between points in spacetime
or the ability to manipulate gravity to
twist and bend space-time to drastically
reduce the distances between two points
now kardashev himself stopped at type
three he said that it was nearly
impossible for a civilization to reach a
galactic level of energy control
but he did think that in time mankind
could progress to a type 2
before we you know
now the clock is ticking and we're only
one meteor away from starting over
then there's the fact that our sun will
expand into a red giant in about five
billion years
and occupy the space we're currently
living in but before that happens
the approaching solar mass will turn the
earth's surface into a scorched
wasteland boiling away all water and
atmosphere
and then it atomizes us so there are a
few problems to solve
nothing like a little existential dread
to ruin my mood
but let's say we do survive all of that
and make it to type 4.
what does that even look like
there is some chance that in the next
few decades we will get
a signal from some spectacularly distant
spectacularly exotic civilization and
everything on earth will as a
consequence change now there have been a
few add-ons to the kardashev scale in
subsequent years
and we covered type zero representing a
primitive civilization that doesn't
appear on the graph
going in the other direction a type four
civilization will be able to harness a
power
output equal to all of the galaxies in
the observable universe
that we can also assume that type 4
civilization would make use of the
energy from black holes and neutron
stars
as well as regular stars now this is so
technologically advanced
that science fiction doesn't really
cover it because it's just too difficult
to wrap our minds around
now for reference star trek is about a
2.2 on the kardashev scale
the asgardians and the mcu are about a
3.2
did you farewell and good luck morons
marvel's masters of the mystic arts
3.3 the star wars stories are considered
right around 3.6
this station is now the ultimate power
in the universe
still not type 4. now if you're able to
control the energy of an entire universe
at type 4
what the heck do you do with type 5 well
say hello to interdimensional beings who
travel the multiverse
and probably through time yep this type
of civilization would be able to
manipulate all the matter and energy
within their own
observable universe and likely travel
beyond it
how do you travel beyond something if
you can't observe it
i i don't know it's too abstract for my
monkey brain
but even more abstract is the type 6
civilization
they're capable of creating universes
and multiverses
and destroying them just as easily they
could step
outside the confines of time influence
future possibilities
branch infinite timelines all at will
now a type 4
civilization would seem like magic to us
but even a single being from a type 5 or
a type 6
would seem like a god no boy
and probably not a benevolent god this
is why many theorists would prefer we
never make contact with anyone
because if we do find an advanced
civilization it would probably mean the
end of our own
the aliens don't have to be evil in
order to be dangerous to us
they might not care they just may not
care about us and in the process pave us
over
if we look at the kardashev scale the
next logical step for us
a move from type 1 to type 2 requires
space exploration
it's likely any extraterrestrials we
encounter are at least a type 2
if not type 3. there's no guarantee
they'd be friendly
there's a strong possibility that if we
get the attention of an intelligent
civilization
they might not be interested in our
friendship but they certainly be
interested in our resources
first contact could be something that
accelerates our own advancement
and improves the quality of life on
earth or
it could be the end of our species we
really have no way of knowing
still there are plenty of people
searching for life the european space
agency broadcasts
3 700 text messages toward polaris
oh boy and breakthrough initiatives is a
program founded in 2015
and funded by billionaire yuri milner
its mission is to search for
extraterrestrial intelligence using
various approaches breakthrough listen
is an effort to search over 1 million
stars for artificial radio or laser
signals
a parallel project called breakthrough
star shot will send a swarm of probes to
the alpha centauri system at about 20
percent the speed of light
now what do you think is this a good
idea now some scientists
most notably stephen hawking are
convinced the answer is a firm
no many scientists have compared
discovering alien life
to columbus or cortez coming to the new
world
and fyi in that comparison humans are
the natives
and things didn't work out that well for
them
when any of us explored the world
with high technology ships and and
came upon a civilization less advanced
it was bad for the less advanced
civilization the kardashev scale
is just one measurement of civilization
but there are others
in 2010 john barrow mathematician and
theoretical physicist
proposed an alternative theory for
measuring civilization
he called it micro dimensional mastery
nabarro said that humans are currently
more cost oriented and that it's more
economical
to manipulate smaller scale environments
than venturing to the cosmos
so his scale is one of decreasing value
now type one would be the ability to
manipulate objects on the same scale as
ourselves like
breaking down rocks to mine ore or to
make building materials from trees
a type 2 is capable of manipulating dna
altering the development and function of
living organisms by replacing
or inserting new genetic code a type 3
is a civilization capable of
manipulating molecular bonds directly
to create entirely new and non-naturally
forming materials
a type 4 can manipulate actual atoms
themselves
nanotechnology that can create
artificial life forms from base matter
now type 5 is the power to change the
atomic nucleus
and stitch it together from subatomic
particles to create designer elements
then a type six can customize most basic
forms of matter
quarks leptons and organize them into a
complex system
this isn't just understanding quantum
physics it's controlling it
and a type omega civilization well they
have complete control over space and
time
now currently we sit somewhere between
types 3 and type
4 in the micro dimensional mastery scale
that means our next step
is artificial life yep we always end up
here don't we
the good old rise of the ai no boy
[Music]
if humanity collectively decides that
creating digital super intelligence is
the right move then
we should do so very very carefully
um very very carefully
okay so back to fermi's paradox which
simply states
if there's so much life in the universe
why can't we find it now a response to
this is in a paper released just last
year by researchers at caltech and jpl
the basic idea of the paper is that the
universe is full of civilizations
dead civilizations that through
technological advancements
eventually killed themselves off this is
why no one's answering our calls
but given our own path and the ominous
presence of apocalyptic weapons
this scenario seems plausible i mean
we're not even close to going
interstellar
but we're certainly capable of
self-annihilation right now
i think this is why we want there to be
advanced life out there
because if another civilization is able
to overcome the risks of technology and
finally travel the stars
then that means we could do it too i
think this is also a reason why people
like science fiction stories that take
place in the far future
not just positive futures like star trek
but darker futures like ender's game or
the matrix or terminator the future may
be dark in these stories
but at least there's a future there's
security and a sense of peace and
knowing that
even though our individual time on earth
is short life
does go on our species will continue
but will it when we finally do find
evidence of intelligent alien life
will that discovery motivate the human
race to use technology to address
problems here on earth so that we can
join the larger community
yeah i wouldn't count on it or if we
find evidence of an extinct civilization
that too should motivate us right
because if we can't evolve past our
selfishness and tribalism
we could share the same fate our future
may be
just like many scientists believe no
future at all
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's hecklefish this has
been the y-files if you had fun or
learned anything today comment like
subscribe share
it really helps out the channel fun i'm
terrified
over here sorry about that anyway until
next time be safe
be kind and know that you are
[Music]
appreciated
you